if there were a portal through which you
could see all of the invisible air
currents temperature gradients and
differences in pressure and composition
of air
then this is what it would look like to
strike a match
this is helium being squeezed out of a
balloon
you could see the warm air rising off
your hands
the invisible vapors of isopropyl
alcohol and the plume of ejected
material when you sneeze this is the
setup for how I made those shots over
here I have a 40 centimeter diameter
concave parabolic mirror normally this
would be used to make a telescope but if
it formed just a tiny piece of a big
spherical shell right a giant spherical
mirror that we're inside then the center
of that mirror would be right here and
that's where I've placed this LED it's
three millimeter but I tried to make the
light source even smaller by painting it
with some black nail polish so we try to
approximate a point source of light
there now that light spreads out in all
directions and it bounces off the mirror
and reflects back almost to exactly the
point where the light is you can see
that the light converges to a point
right there now I've offset the light
just a little bit so that this light
will pass straight through and into the
lens of my camera so right here I
position this razor blade so it cuts off
about half the light passing through
this setup allows you to see tiny
variations in what is in front of the
mirror for example when you have hot
gases coming off of a candle well you
can see that because as the reflected
light from the LED passes through this
column of hot air it changes directions
ever so slightly that is it refracts and
the reason for that is because the
refractive index of hot air is different
from the refractive index of the cooler
air around it now refractive index is a
measure of how fast light travels
through a medium relative to its speed
in a vacuum so for air the value is
pretty close to 1 but hotter air
actually has a lower index of refraction
in this case the difference in
refractive index is incredibly tiny and
so we don't notice the deflection of the
light but with this setup it actually
makes a difference
because some of the light that would
have passed over this razor blade
instead gets deflected down and gets
blocked and that forms a darker spot on
the image similarly some light that
would have hit the razor blade is
instead deflected over it creating a
brighter spot on the image and that is
how this works so you can see the heat
rising off your head and you can see
your breath and you can see the cold air
poured out of a cup of ice but
temperature is not the only thing that
affects the refractive index different
materials different substances they have
different refractive indices for example
the butane in a lighter obviously we
can't see that it's coming out right now
but the camera can even before the
lighter is lipped
light also refracts when it passes
through a bubble and the amount depends
on the thickness of that bubble film
this technique is known as schlieren
based on the german word leer which
means streak and it was first observed
in 1665 by Robert Hooke who was using
two candles and some lenses then in the
nineteenth century they used this method
to try to find defects in the glass used
to make lenses and more recently people
have used salir in to study aerodynamics
and fluid flow because it allows you to
see those pressure differences in
temperature gradients so you can look at
shockwaves and differences in the
composition of gases so when you watch
the lighting of this match you're seeing
heat generated from friction igniting
phosphorus which in turn generates more
heat and begins the reaction between
sulfur and potassium chlorate which
releases sulfur dioxide which you can
also see
and you can see my breath as I blow out
the flame
I am so excited that I got this set up
to work so if you can think of anything
that would look really cool and clear in
then let me know in the comments and I
will try to make it happen and if you're
new to this channel we'll click here to
subscribe I've got some awesome videos
coming up very soon
you